people who
[Music]
are dissidents to establish an orthodoxy
for good or for bad right are the people
who
become the most threatening and
therefore the most attacked and the most
demonized how would you know so i guess
let's talk about tucker a little bit
what does he have to do where it's like
something happens and he disappears i
think you know one i think the tactic
that you saw is remember after that
massacre in buffalo where
the guy who was influenced by the people
he said he was influenced by a long list
of people not tucker carlson right um
you know went into a a grocery store in
a particularly in a prominently black
part of town that he chose for that
reason and shot 10 people instantly
there was an attempt to put the blood of
those people at the doorstep of tucker
carlson so i think
the strategy is to isolate him as this
grave threat that we cannot tolerate i
don't remember but
glenn beck had a bigger audience at five
o'clock hour which is not a very you
know it's not a great popular hour for
television then tucker had i mean he had
he was breaking insane amounts of
records and at the peak of his
popularity he was off fox news
because he had become so radioactive to
establishment
uh prerogatives that no
advertiser was willing to touch him and
fox got rid of them even though he was
bringing in many millions of people
so
i think there's a line that you can't
cross no matter how large your audience
size is and i think tucker is flirting
with that line and you saw
the kind of
attempt to basically start to say that
he is too dangerous to all on air